she's looking got a lot longer than
three warnings morning oh I like that
good morning I like the other way you're
the first one morning I like that one
better you do I do
okay yeah it does it seems that well you
know I feel like where do we have a
short week in LA yeah we went a short
week here no me in a short week here and
this week is kind of short well it is
it's four days
I know but hate starting Tuesday and
Thursday that's me guy well you're a
TGIF kid that's right it's okay it
happens you know hope everybody had a
great long Memorial Day weekend do you
have fun
I went to LA I had nothing to do so I
wanted this I just went out there and
did nothing I ate like a pig
and gives you jetsedder look it's just
Hollywood Jim Norton just at the last
minute you know what I have nothing to
do
might as well be bicoastal it's not that
hard to do that anyways I'm like you
know in 1950s where that was jet-setting
like I'm Tom Hagen yeah yeah I'm gonna
take it for a bug 185 right now hundred
bucks yeah Robert Kelly it's like
JetBlue hi buddy hey Robert Sam bones
what's up we drove in together oh did
you kind of on the phone virtually
together oh that's nice he was in front
of me and then I passed him and then we
pulled up at the same time and then he
passed me yeah technically I got into
garage first technically but we're just
being cute would be cute yeah it seems
cute we had a little conversation yeah
he called me because he was complaining
about traffic driving in and we realized
that we were very close to each other on
the West Side Highway yeah so we just
stayed on the phone and I let him know
there was a road closure I was like
don't turn on 48th better turn on 5th
didn't help me but the cutest part of
the conversation when we were in the
garage and we were right next to each
other we could see each other and all
right I'll talk to you in a sec cool
I'll talk to you one second that was
really nice it's right Bob Kelly was
waiting like a good boy because there
was a line of cars to get into the
entrance now but the exit was fallen
clear so I told him on the phone I said
Oh see you later Bobby what's this the
exit and just drove right in the exit no
problem the relations you know guys that
was pretty
I was engineering TBS I think TBS would
like this I was yeah two douches two
[ __ ] on the Westside Highway
I caught Westchester boys that's
actually a great name for a show yeah I
would say like in in high school or even
in college like just people who go like
man our group of friends is so wild they
should make a reality show about us yeah
you're like no they know they should
yeah oh you drive in and talk on the
phone right guys are so close they don't
even stop talking on the highway they
said that when you were in high school
were in high school they didn't have
reality shows no no no they didn't this
had three shows yeah or cell phones they
never would have done that that really
what do you mean you called them from
your car you guys have walkie-talkies
you just went and celebrated it was oh
yeah just to do something was a little
boring but I mean it was just I had
nothing planned and I hung out with with
[ __ ] my manager and his wife and my I
saw my ex and I saw some friends and it
was just I just ate that was it
there's nothing sounds great it sounds
like you were living your best life I
just wanted to get out of New York right
I know in my mind I'm back on Efrain so
I sound like [ __ ] I'm not sleeping
against my [ __ ] nose is stuffy well
you're probably jet-lagged no the night
before I went home like I can't sleep I
got to take something and then now my
[ __ ] nose you [ __ ] yourself up
totally I'm ruined
so I don't understand you use Efrain
does that make everything worse after
yes but in the moment it makes you sleep
sure but then the next day it's like
someone took a sock and shoved it in
your sinuses she gets stuff he knows
today not now no I saw him on Afrin last
night you can hear it yeah katt right
you don't sound nasally yeah I apologize
there's nothing to like it but once it
wears off
I'll saw something what what is it we're
on you know at first you have 24 hours
and the second time it's like 15 or 16
and then it's down to 12 so is there a
potential that like towards the last
hour of the show today I don't think so
that fast but it probably happened
before I'm home I have the gym and I
have a doctor's appointment or I be like
Rose what's the doctor's appointment was
therapy Oh therapy right you call it a
doctor no I just said that's how animal
right I have therapy today too I haven't
seen him in three weeks no I'm a little
nervous why I know did he scold you when
you haven't gone in no he doesn't he
doesn't scold me so what are you nervous
about
yeah no no you see much you're doing
great I'm doing you know it's a weird
thing is that I've been I've been pretty
good for the last so I've had a really
good time the last three weeks uh like
real good so I'm like do I need this
[ __ ] guy I think that about meetings
sometimes still I'm like do I really
need this [ __ ] you know did I do it I
suppose done you're supposed to keep
going to treatment when you feel better
because then all of a sudden yeah you
know you feel worse and you go what
happened I don't understand yeah oh I'll
[ __ ] yeah I'll lose my mind on the
way home traffic something will happen
today but I'll just [ __ ] when I stab
somebody
oh me too grab the ceiling the wheel and
just smoosh it the ceiling wheel see
it's all messy you know about the
ceiling I do in Westchester they put all
the steering wheels on the top of the
car that's a Bob would imagine with you
steering when he's in his bed when he
was a youngster just kind of just what
was happening like it wordy yeah
thinking you're stealing wheel as
there's a mouth on your Peter I'm just
driving the bus again the ceiling wheel
look I'm driving the house no I'm still
in charge I'm driving here beard
bristles are tickling your thighs and
beard bristles I always you know those
people that actually find out they were
molested like in their 40s just it just
appeared I don't think so no I believe
yes I don't think Oh Sam you can't say
that did I think Jim was my yeah you can
why not I was a kid if I wasn't molested
there's a [ __ ] pedophile crisis I was
adorable the pedophile should be drummed
out in New Jersey I was a [ __ ] nine
and a half their own Germany for three
years
of course I missed out they missed out a
little Jimmy are you really dorable oh
boy was I yeah oh I'll show you a
picture as a boy
really oh okay it's getting weird Bob
really really let me see the photo you
sent jerking off to the photos you seen
this thing so you're worried about going
your therapist um yeah I think the last
time we left and we were gonna start
talking about sex you know tell me you
wanna be friends if I get under the
money to pay him so I have that option
anymore so we have to work out some good
genes do you not want to talk about do
not want to talk about you okay look at
this let me can I see a photo remember
it makes me tear up how cute you are all
right you see there that picture Jim how
old would you say Jim Norton is in that
photo Bob he's five
okay so maybe five four or five four or
five years old he's adorable right oh my
anyway you see that what you see the
bandage on his head yeah it's sad how do
you how did you get that bandage on your
head Jim I was running away from boy
whose penis I used to suck and I fell
and hit my head on the concrete steps
used to suck past tense
at that age five five you say he's not
molested that's my age stop for a second
though he might not be molested maybe he
just like penis I mean it's not a maybe
I'm asleep and I'm listening to my
parents talking of the dead I think you
like if you like penis you're probably
not gonna run away from it so quickly
that you smash your head on a rock you'd
run away from it as a take a game like
we played a game Jimmy no I was just
frightened of him Oh was he trying to no
he was with his other friend they were
just bullies that's whatever it
are they were making you suck em no no
the whole thing well I'm sorry we have
pretty clear it means pretty clear what
happened can I just say something it
makes me sad and and does that affect
you like when you see that yeah but I've
seen I've heard the story huh yeah I
know but like now that you have a son
just like you a man
does that affect you at all I'd like I
imagine your son at five I can't even go
there you can't mentally yeah it's sad
dude oh come on
the first brought me boys will be boys
it's let you have to give yourself some
credit because you have taken all this
horrible [ __ ] in your life and created a
[ __ ] Empire I'm not I would okay
Empire USA Empire I'm a humor brand I
like that yeah an empire of humor
birthright I sense I would top the
gesture with the broken crown and a sore
heinie
I mean has it not made it okay for guys
alpha males cuz I'm on an alpha male I'm
[ __ ] bill beta you're not building
you're an alpha male compared to who
yeah I wouldn't say physically I would
say physically I mean you would pose no
threat physically come on except to a
pile of dirt and maybe an apple but I
think mentally you're an alpha male I
think mentally you're I gym you how you
you are you you can use this very strong
language
well he's nobody's very easy he's
aggressive he doesn't take [ __ ] I mean
you know you're assertive on steady huh
you if somebody [ __ ] you yo-yo Adam
you know you'll [ __ ] say [ __ ] you back
that's and you'll no loss of you argue
with them and use philosophy and you'll
you'll win arguments I mean when I ranch
their fists alright our yeah then he
turns into a [ __ ] ball of jell-o the
guy punches him his hand just bounces
back that's right but do you know I mean
you've made a [ __ ] you've made a
insane career out of all your [ __ ]
fucked-up [ __ ] you know it's funny
you're talking about the Jim Norton
comedy brand yeah exactly yeah comedy
brand yeah the Norton bring you somebody
pointed out to me recently like yeah ok
considering this [ __ ] you talking about
yes yeah I I did not a guess most people
who have
Steve stay victims carrot with him as a
secret their whole lives and I'm not a
victim and I don't think anybody who has
that happen to them as a victim but no
some people are okay I'm saying to
remain a victim you were back then
yeah no you were back then I was having
fun no you weren't having fun how's your
head on the rock because you're so
scared that's how one kid do you know
you can't run okay so you're having fun
yeah that's not I was running from him
she was gonna beat me up the other night
[Laughter]
but you you you would the same things
true about you right Bobby I had a I had
a fucked-up childhood but Dad I I this
is what this is why I say about Jim and
he was the first one to kind of do it
we're not the first one of course I
Pryor did it but but he went on stage
and really and even in radio it revealed
himself fully not worrying about what we
thought or what the audience thought
just said [ __ ] it this is who I am I
know I'm this and we got to laugh at it
and it opened up a bunch of other people
to be able to go go on the radio and
reveal themselves and now you don't live
with it now it isn't you're not you're
not living with it being in a room full
of funny [ __ ] and there's these
secrets you don't have any secrets you
know which is pretty incredible
I have something but nothing terrible or
nothing awful nothing no I mean we
pretty much know what you do if you've
told everybody and you've made fun of it
and you've let us make fun of it that's
pretty [ __ ] crazy though I mean I
went to kiss in LA it was fun I saw your
photos what a store called Keith what is
it I don't know it was stupid it's a big
it's it's a it was one in New York
there's one in LA it's a big popular
sneaker store I was there I mean I
stopped there when we were there for the
show like I made time to go there cuz I
was like let me check out we happen to
be looking at this other store and I
just decided to go in and just [ __ ]
look around it was it was fun did you
buy anything yeah no look at his shoe no
he didn't I know he got that shoe in
Denmark it's a plastic clog show I
haven't have a nice shoe look at that's
not a good [ __ ] a good shoe
Jim appreciates a solid shoe ok likes a
solid shoe a nice plant the Fisher a
minute what is that that's a new shoe
just my shoe that's it that's a European
boot with chillin so that's a walking
shoe the old shoe without looking I
don't know guys I just want to talk
about it what is it Troy there's boost
on the end of that isn't there ok that's
right in between those are those aren't
they yeah guys come on I don't want them
and how are your wide feet doing in them
they're ok actually they're not as I
thought your ease yeah they're not as
bad as I thought but I bought I bought
I'm not try me see how they are I had my
manager shipping my old shoes back with
other stuff I booked if my suitcase was
too small I threw him out in a giant no
no not him I need him for the furnace
rainy and stuff what am I gonna wear
yeah gonna wear those you like these
though yeah no I'll get more yeah you
got it you got to get a whole bunch of
sneakers now I will huh yeah I'm gonna
start buying some sneakers oh no I love
Jim stepping up his game yeah well I'd
rather have you addicted to sneakers
than the other stuff that's not going
anywhere I'm just slicing the pie up a
little bit yeah we can go to kids in New
York at night I don't need to go there
again the sneakers were ok that's
expensive 160 bucks just like it's that
[ __ ]
there's other places to go to in the
city right no plenty but I'm really
surprised that you went to cath I mean
kids like a really cool spot no I was ok
I just we were looking at Fred Segal
there's a we went in for coffee Fred
Segal is a cool story of all kinds of
weird [ __ ] and like you know good
colognes and on Melrose no there's a new
one from the film clueless ok yeah and
then from the garage you can get into
kit it was like the entrance is like on
the garage level it was a rear entrance
interrupt that Hill yeah yeah it was an
OK store yeah yeah I mean it's it's it's
a super popular store right now those
guys outside
oh we drove by those guys sitting out
front and mama they must be waiting for
sneakers it was like Friday afternoon
and they had knew she was coming out
Monday or today so they're gonna be
there all weekend yeah supreme and stuff
here what do they cost eager head is
that we think our heads yeah is that
you're a sneakerhead
I don't know I don't see those Bob yeah
huh I like labels
what about our sneakers no I mean I like
that I'm not gonna make it without a way
yeah you're you you're a sneaker I like
I like the culture I like and I like
sneakers yeah how much of those sneakers
you were now these ones are cheap these
ones you can get for retailer like 150
160 that's cheap yeah yeah these ones
you can you can store these are the game
royal Jordan ones you could find him for
retail there Wow there yeah everybody
the oddest papas isn't Chrissy chris d
sneaker game uh was it but paul virzi
you have a pauper's young I think I know
Paul he works at her a lot he's funny
are you gonna have probably had him
honor I know I talked to him feel like
he's been on but I do yeah I think I'm
almost positively I pulled it yes
[ __ ] great but he's a big see he
won't if you get a crease in him he
won't wear him right why buy two pairs
so why I'm covered white one so they
don't [ __ ] do that for the same they
don't crease them when to rock when the
stock dude of all the things you want to
protect sneakers are hard because
they're on your [ __ ] feet well plus I
mean it becomes such an obvious the one
thing to protect but if you're in a
sense of your car it's in the elements
if you collect [ __ ] that you hang in the
house it's [ __ ] easy to keep it safe
like your shoes you're working with if
the things are inside they stay Captain
Obvious findings you're just making a
mockery of a boy stop this from getting
dirty place it on a table I'm Captain
Obvious
place it inside on a table and never
touch it come up with this little riff
on the way are you [ __ ] we brainstorm
we had a Raiders Captain Obvious just
wait for Jim saying so but if you get
deeper and deeper into it like I'm at
the point now where I went over over the
weekend and I bought like six six packs
[ __ ] yeah
Nick DiPaolo episode how great how great
was Nick on it though I Nick was awesome
suck it chip I thought Nick was awesome
on the last chip I could literally have
Nick on everything I would agree when I
loved it it's almost the perfect guest
yeah who's finally Apollo in a [ __ ]
sailor hat hat on incredible but he went
with it
he did he did I [ __ ] hate chip but I
got like six six packs of plastic shoe
boxes to store things like against the
wall so I could put that's where I keep
all my sneakers now and then I'm getting
to the point where like all my
collection of shoes that are still in
the box yeah that I just leave in the
box there's a thing with Jordans did the
paper that they packed them in yeah over
time it will like leave like a shiny
glittery residue on the sneaker like if
you leave it in there for months or
years the paper so I'm sitting there
going like well I don't want to so I
think I have to go through all my shoes
and take out the paper or at least fold
the paper at the bottom so that they're
not wrapped in the paper anymore you
know this like we're stuck without water
somewhere Liz I know I know in that food
today and I'm sitting there going like
hey what do I have well I have to take
the paper out because I don't want a
shiny glitter on my shoes detector
investment exactly why don't you get a
pair of toms protect your investment
that's what I say every time put a
condom on which is never so you've never
set up ever
you don't wear these silly stairs I want
to go to this 12-under
okay Kevin in Philly what's up buddy
gentlemen yes I literally I'm reading
what you said and I have no idea what
you're talking about I truly don't know
what you're talking about
nobody's have a podcast and it was a
serrated Greg Hughes is aka Oh be new
podcast October did beyond any level you
guys have ever done
Wow
it's amazing that's oh okay but you're
saying you're saying instead of talking
stickers tell about his meltdown
what kind of meltdowns if you have I
truly don't know you're talking about it
would cause the meltdown because he's
gonna do the whole you know I [ __ ]
didn't oh okay so a podcast kind of jock
tobert him
what's the podcast I did it I have no
idea they're a bunch of nobodies but at
that tons of leverage oh okay look I'm
gonna tell you something all right well
thanks Kevin III didn't hear I thought
he said he said Opie's meltdown like I
don't know what he's talking about
I'm Way too worried about the damage
that the tissue paper is gonna do to my
that stock sneakers I'm happy that that
happened by the way to worry about any
of this I [ __ ] love it if he took it
out and his dumb sneakers all had
[ __ ] wax paper melted to him alright
it's yeah because it's a just look I
have all these boxes and I'm like why am
i buying these second pairs that they're
just talking to get glittery it's a
terrible thing
I made me so happy I don't even know why
a shoe company would do that why would
you you're supposed to take your shoes
out you don't they they don't [ __ ]
put it the last forever
why would food make things that have an
expiration date you're gonna eat it's
not and just look at it [ __ ] shoes
why would they make milk that's spoiled
yes exactly
there was a bunch of [ __ ] lunatics
collecting them there's sneakers they
knew by now they know they cost $22 to
make there's a little kid making them in
China and you guys buy them for five
bills and put them in a closet you guys
how much do you think that your shoes
cost seventeen hundred bucks
the a dog you have a dog yeah these are
actually a dogs oh the souls I have
different soldier to put on these like a
hiking sole of rollerblade sole you
there's a rock climbing sole yeah these
have different souls I see them you pop
them on it pop them off yeah these are
these I try to pop them all I called I
don't have the soul I need the soul okie
dokie okie I I like the converse the
ultra Taylor Chuck Taylors John Varvatos
yeah my shoe I hate John Varvatos why
don the outfits you look great you know
like those issue would matter John
Varvatos you know I saw the name what
Varvatos
me it's kind of like I wanna I want to
hear Troy chime in on that
what John Varvatos I mean not to me but
I'm a big fan of the converse I'm gonna
say something and I don't say to be
offensive I can't fit in it
John Varvatos is kind of for like pretty
older people that kind of rock do drop
kids kind of don't really know what
school woody my kids like like in mid
40s mid mid life maybe even alright
Rolling Stone oh really yes
though there could there converse the
armour circle I remember there's a
[ __ ] best do you think this guy lists
some of this guy [ __ ] uh well I was
gonna say because we were talking about
Memorial Day weekend okay and I did want
to ask you if he saw Trump's tweet about
Memorial Day I did not but I know he's I
know he's getting [ __ ] and I was too
busy watching everybody kill Ivanka just
for saying that she liked having her kid
and she was happy with her kid or
whatever she was saying what did Ivanka
say that people were man yeah they said
was tone deaf because she was just
holding up her baby and just looking at
the baby why is that turned us because
of what's been happening with the
[ __ ] up kids being taken away from
their parents but ever like your own
baby I know I know I mean yeah so the
controversy I guess is that there are
migrants migrant children are being lost
by the government they've misplaced
1,500 kids but at the same time I spent
the weekend enjoying my child Bob I'm
assuming enjoyed his child Ivanka
probably enjoyed her chunk that great
weekend right exactly you didn't bother
you that the 1,500 migrant children were
missing who right right exactly right so
it's between the read his tweet um I
supposed to stay home I've been
depressed it well I can we go play know
there's migrant children innocent yes
children missing how dare you play in
that backyard like what's a migrant
child but it's with you but with a Dan
you live somewhere else with no food and
what you're missing so Donald Trump
sweets out put that I put that iPhone
and iPad down and all you get out of
your toy room cuz you're so sad about
missing children get off that zipline I
just bought you and put up did you run a
zip line yeah Bob goes over the top
sometimes I love it I built I built the
platform
all [ __ ] with him you come over I well
with the birthday parties soon right
soon yeah yeah okay Donald Trump tweeted
happy Memorial Day those who died for
our great country would be very happy
and proud and how well our country is
doing Texel ensuite best he's not done
oh yeah unfortunately Oh best economy in
decades lowest unemployment numbers for
blacks and Hispanics ever and women in
18 years rebuilding our military and so
much more then he follows it up nice his
capitalisation I leaves a little
something to be desired you don't
capitalize blacks and military they're
not then Hispanics is a nation or you
know he just throws cap when he thinks
it works because he really likes like me
here's the same grammar as me point the
capitalization and military yeah it
doesn't make any sense that's not that
you don't capitalize or military nation
point do you like the exclamation point
at the end of nice yeah I don't like I
don't mind once in a while but overuse
of exclamation points is literally the
biggest sign of being a [ __ ] writer when
you look at people who overuse
exclamation points they have so little
faith in what they're saying they think
they have to stress it with punctuation
see your show at the end go you were the
best and put nine exclamation points at
the end of it but you see once in a
while if you're saying I went to this
concert it was great alright that's
something you put exclamation point but
people who are like and then we got home
and we were all tired what the [ __ ] you
for your exclamation points right about
what are you so excited about you also
the word nice there's no reason for that
word to be in there and we went down and
we weren't sure what was waiting for us
exclamation point
how excited are you [ __ ] you it depends
on how you use the word nice if you go
if you go nice you don't need a but if
you're going nice about you and then he
shotguns off or if you're just taking
your zipper and pulling it on going nice
yeah I would say with this
nice just amazing the drug from read the
tweet
did he just wrote a tweet complimenting
himself and then he read the compliments
and wrote nice nice I'm doing good nice
nice wow you're just funny watching all
like the Memorial Day tributes on one
hand you have people doing it
appropriately where they're like look at
all the people that and I just watched
Saving Private Ryan the night before and
so it was like oh my god these people
they make the ultimate sacrifice I can't
believe it their families go through
it's off did you like it
Saving Private Ryan it's great hey I
haven't seen in years but it was really
good especially that opening sighting
like that was one part I'd like we've
seen terribly shot you don't like the
Normandy terrible shot loud too loud too
many people falling yeah and what's it
was too much gunshots glorifying
violence I didn't care for it I felt
like I was there and I don't if I wanted
to be there I just I would I'd go to war
and absolutely right I'm here I don't
even Ormandy is that right be there 100%
right lighten it up but yeah to go from
like watching this Saving Private Ryan
at Normandy and all this stuff and going
through all the families and everything
and then looking at everybody's tributes
and they're going like oh you know you
feel so bad in the ultimate sacrifice
and families and then Donald Trump it's
like hey but how great am i doing look
what I've got going on over here
nice nice I know your grandfather's dead
good for him but check this if your
grandfather was alive he'd be able to
see me doing all this stuff
nice yeah your daddy died in Vietnam you
didn't really know him your life's a
little [ __ ] up but now it's better you
know why unemployment rate is down and
blacks who weren't allowed to to live
the same way they used to now there
aren't employment rate is down to nice
we're looking at a porno Troy were of
course shaving Ryan's privates okay it's
a bunch of men around one man they're
all helping shave his general hair
helpful boys looks like a bunch of owene
fans to know one guy is leaning back and
they're all wearing military pants and
they're all looking at the camera and
apparently this man needs is private as
genital shaved so there's five other
gentlemen trying to
helped him shave but I love the one guy
reaching and just holding onto the shaft
that's how the race doesn't hit it
that's being helpful that's very good
yeah after shaving Ryan's privates ever
since that movie has come out I've done
the I mean I you know when I was a kid
the saving Ryan's privates joke you just
flip the words around uh-huh I have
never thought to make it shaving Ryan's
private yeah that makes much more sense
much better movie than saving Ryan's
privates oh you like shaving oh my god
you like that right yeah film yeah
poorly shot you know funny Sharon eight
millimeter Sony I tried to throw Sony
and to say I understood I went a
millimeter nothing so no you messed up
you know what the end should have been
yep I do wish the people would Sam go
thank you
we just have fun with stuff like this
though like when the president does
something foolish like that just like we
could Joe what about it but they used to
we you know we used to have fun with
this horseshit no now it's outrage now
it's the end of the world is coming
every [ __ ] day right as usual e what
comedians it's like can't you just be
funny George Carlin hated a lot of [ __ ]
and was angry with a lot and he just
wrote about it and he made the people
that he hated laugh at them right even
though they didn't know he wouldn't
always tell them he was talking about
but here the way of taking the audience
would be 3,000 people in the audience
and he'd be attacking a certain thing
but it's like he's attacking half the
people in the audience and they're still
going with him he ran it was
unbelievable that but that's what we're
supposed to do and really the only way
you're gonna like ever change anybody's
mind which is difficult enough anyway
but you're not gonna do it by
reprimanding them go like no this is
what it's if you can make somebody laugh
that's something that they thought was
true but like oh that is actually kind
of funny that's not all comics get off
Twitter except for Colin Quinn it's we
shouldn't be on it it's stupid we does
nothing so fun yeah it does enough the
problem with comedies and Twitter's stop
trying to stop trying to be so poignant
right once
while you want to make a point fine but
you know people like us because we're
funny you're trying to be funny
let's just shut the [ __ ] up and try to
be funny sometimes but if you're not
being funny don't ever be serious yeah I
mean I mean don't try to go on there and
MIT I mean every once in a while you can
say something make it say but how many
look at you're gonna Anthony to go to
Paulo I mean [ __ ] takes guys yeah
careers away yeah Twitter not there
podcaster radio shows Twitter well see
yeah it's one thing away people can grab
it and it looks bad in print there's no
content it's just look what I said and
you could send it everywhere there's no
effort to listen to at home you can't
find tone at all yeah but it said Dane
Cook started at all he became big on
MySpace and then people slow like that
here and there people started becoming
kind of Twitter famous and I think a lot
of young comics are going like oh whoa
you know I'm going to open mics or
whatever but if I can build an audience
on Twitter
I can I can get ahead of the game Rob
Delaney do that yeah he's picking
England he's got a show yeah
and he's just a Deadpool yeah yeah he
was uh was Paul Wright
I don't know I only watch the first not
a Deadpool to vary was it bad no I just
left the we've got there early so we
snuck into the first 15 minutes a devil
2 and then went to a quiet place crash
how is it quiet place I want to see that
great ok so it's still in the theaters
yeah ok I got I gotta get a young lady
and go so ladies who ever wants to see a
quiet place
hit me up put parentheses around ladies
nayana Bob I'm telling you I'm looking
for something forgive me for saying this
somebody with a [ __ ] shaking things up a
little that's right I want looks like
somebody is freshening things up I don't
wanna have to spit on my dick no more I
just want to put it in and have the
juices take over yeah somebody I want to
see that movie that looks really good
yeah you should see you soon I'll be out
of theaters very okay what is this
weekend a quiet quiet place it's scary
movie yes we're basically there are
monsters that can hear but they can't
see and so you have to be quiet all the
time because if they hear you they come
out isn't it a t-rex
t-rex is have eyes yes yeah but they
really can't see do you know what
the noises that this is were the problem
is they can only hear certain tones so
they said but everyone does it and then
that's when they come out and get you
it's like if it's really quiet and you
go I wish people were like that he's get
sucked into the wall and they'd be
amazing it's really scary I think like
the idea concept of it I've heard it's
good I've saw the trailer and people
said look it was [ __ ] horrifying so I
want to see it yeah it's good that's not
in the film how fast you think rich
would die rich Voss with my news I made
a move what is your name is CD yeah I
mean I don't want to give away too much
of it because there are lots of little
plot points and things in twists and
they're having this is one of the few
movies yeah right is that there and I
said man this is one of the few movies
that didn't give everything away in the
trailer nice I saw Deadpool yeah and it
was [ __ ] great I just wanted to see
the Avengers movie that everybody's
talking about everyone loves this
Avengers movie yeah they moved it to the
little theaters and all the movie
theaters it was sold out this weekend
great I'm [ __ ] The Avengers movie was
the best one so far that's why I went to
the quiet Thanos is the best villain in
any of the movies although we had to
move to a different movie theater to
find a quiet place and Jess was like oh
I'm sorry I should have bought two
tickets in advance blah blah and I was
like no here's what I assume happens and
I don't know if I was correct or not but
I was able to put together very very
credible probably true plots for
Deadpool - and for Avengers just based
on the fact that all the superhero
movies are kind of the same but good I'm
not gonna go through the whole thing oh
look at four hours they're not even
three three oh you guys accounting by a
place quietly I don't want to go by
myself
well who are you looking for what are
you looking for in the person somebody
with a [ __ ] okay
but one of the things that you need a
head somebody with a [ __ ] and a head so
you want somebody that wants to see a
quiet place somebody that's got a head
and somebody who has a [ __ ]
yes and at least one arm one on Thursday
what about legs optional okay so
amputees are fine sure as long as no cuz
every need better seats the whole thing
up front okay yes I see it this weekend
huh yeah I would recommend it it was
really gonna wet in LA I was so stupid
yeah very stupid you think that's okay
that's okay we all make huge mistake I
was literally just eating like a little
piggy who are you eating nothing
[ __ ] food I went out on a boat with
Jonathan and his wife and my ex and me
and their dog Murray was it just you
guys
yeah with us a little boat it was cold
Sunday afternoon where'd you get a
Marina del Rey I know it's down by
stupors down by long brown beach beach
because i wanted to see the [ __ ]
place richard pryor shot that special in
1970 saw the video there yeah it's still
there that's that I figure was called
the theatre at Long Beach whatever does
Jonathan have a boat
no he rented one and he's actually a
good boat driver and they brought all
kinds of snacks
somebody call the boat they call him
boat wreck boat captain well yeah we do
the ship you're actually a captain when
you're driving the boat you become the
captain captain maritime law says
whoever is driving the boat is the
captain that's like saying an airplane
driver yeah maybe you're right
no say that it's captain captain to
captain the boat captain Jonathan you
were the co-captain I know I didn't know
anything I just ate the scent about
goldfish on let me tell you something
about goldfish there's that [ __ ] no
better food than little yellow Gulf you
said on a boat orange fish and I ate
[ __ ] chocolate covered almonds and I
ate salami did anything that any seals
jump on the boat and try to high-five
you it kind of sounds like you were just
eating a lunchable that really very a
childish lunch but it was fun little
little chili on the water I had to piss
a lot you have a windbreaker
I was one
that's rude did you did you pee on them
off the side of the Miss John's wife was
there and [ __ ] you know and there's
people on the bed it was just two people
the students riding around these little
dumb
they look like bicycles but they're on
like a little chippy jet skis yeah
no no not jet skis even like a surfboard
almost like an exercise thing surf we
pulled over Jonathan pull up a dock and
we pissed once went to a bathroom was
fun so annoying is that having a pull
you know how it is to pull a [ __ ]
dump both your coat over after we yeah
oh especially the amount of times Jim
needs to pee Oh every four five mins to
get pulled over
you don't chime in there about my
genital habits
I had the P once I wasn't that bad
actually cause I did pretty knows if you
go on the boat with Jim you have to give
him an empty gatorade bar yeah yeah I
remember I was in the car with [ __ ]
come back from a Black Sabbath concert
and I was with my I was with my buddy
and he had to piss and we were in the
back and and [ __ ] he'd want to pull
over so he has a jar that he travels
with and he just pisses into a jar he
was [ __ ] kneeling away from me facing
the back of the thing pissing a memo
stated Patrice's that's right it was
Ozzy Osbourne I stayed up at Rita's
house once he had a big like you jug
next to his bed and he was just bad he
didn't want to wake up in the middle and
angle P so he just pissing the thing Wow
I understand that empty it they see oh
yeah weird I used to maybe my parents
are probably piss into a jar I had that
it's really odd and now you just do it
right under the bed sometimes I do if I
get nervous yeah but then you have to
get up and change the sheet through that
was up to thirty times last night
pissing it's it's insane really the
amount of tinkles when I was in what is
that you don't go see the amount of
tinkles how many tinkles were there just
an endless amount that's your prostate
right yeah my price is fine I've had it
sauna crammed it's fine it's your brain
yeah that's what my body - your brain is
in your body yeah
when I was a kid there's a Cub Scout we
were on a school bus you know we were
probably on a camping trip or something
and I had to pee and they brought a
Gatorade bottle on the bus and they made
all the scouts that had to pee piss in
the same bottle and so I did one creepy
Scoutmaster tuck it away somewhere
the woman's smell it and [ __ ] jerk
myself off freak yeah I don't know whose
idea this whole thing well it's his his
stickers on it from the years yeah we
below yes yeah I remember you uniform
your little legs yeah I used to say look
at those little smooth toothpicks okay
so he said I give you raspberries I
didn't want to do it I know I don't want
to I don't want to get a baggie unless
it's terrible it's so good place we ever
want to put your lips on a kid is this
an intimate area it's worse than the
penis it is that followed soon after
Jesus Jesus just remove all subtlety
gone now I didn't want to use it
obviously the bottle that is but I held
it in until like towards the end of the
trip when I finally had to and I used it
right and then they were like oh you
know the rules and I was like what and
they were like last Scout that uses the
bottle has to bring it home I was like
what I'm not doing that I'm not gonna
take the bottle home no and the
Scoutmaster was like no Sam you have to
take the bottle no like really
forcefully it's like he handed me the
bottle and I took it and I immediately
just put it on the parking lot and went
home I'm like I'm not yeah not taking
this whole [ __ ] ideas but I don't
know why this Scout man I want to do it
so cuz you want to throw it out he
probably yield he's like yeah let's get
a little [ __ ] piss hand Roberts what
now its second now it was left in an
elementary school parking lot I'm like
I'm not why would you give this to a kid
to bring home it's disgusting most gross
yeah I don't think you could do that
nowadays I don't think you give a kid a
bottle of the whole Scout troops piss
and have him bring it home I I just went
camping with Ari Shaffir and Joe list up
up in the Catskills are you at the
Bushwick Boys no bushcraft boy Oh
bushcraft party boys oh sorry
don't [ __ ] it up I'm called yourself the
bushcraft party boy were the bushcraft
party boys right yeah that's not we
that's that's what we're called you Joe
list
Ari Shaffir we're adding new people who
could be the fourth we're figuring it
out you want to go overnight camping out
in the woods I'd rather ride through
parking lots and find the bottle he left
you'd love it you'd actually like the
hiking part and oh my god I [ __ ] hate
it why I hate hiking why do you think
everybody likes hiking hiking stinks I
knew that I loved it's all uneven
grounding twigs yeah [ __ ] that bugs [ __ ]
you you got a car right yeah I despise I
despise hiking I had to [ __ ] as soon as
we got the camp you have to go do you
have to go 150 feet away from the camp
or a river or the trail you have to find
a spot and then you have to dig a hole
and then you have to [ __ ] in the hole
the [ __ ] [ __ ] outside squatting down
like you're supposed to [ __ ] a rope it
was the greatest [ __ ] I've ever taken
it was just fat and it was just [ __ ]
well then wipe with it I I've toilet
paper and then I use one baby wipe wipe
toilet paper goes in the hall and then
one little baby wipe where's the baby
wife go the baby wipe goes in a plastic
bag and then you throw it away
there was no [ __ ] on it there was no
[ __ ] I wiped it's your body's little
peanut butter no I laid it wasn't bad a
plastic bag in your knapsack no it's in
the trash now well I mean why'd you
carry it to carry your [ __ ] [ __ ] wife
okay yeah that sounds fun yeah you can't
I mean I usually as toilet paper
biodegradable butt wipes or not yeah
whoo the wipes a night I see yeah
but the [ __ ] it looked like I've never
seen a [ __ ] cuz you just [ __ ] and it
goes down the drain
boiling your [ __ ] you have to like cover
it back up you get to see your [ __ ] like
in the Sun did you like it
it was great you're impressed by it it
was [ __ ] and then it looked like there
was little eggs eggs little egg [ __ ] so
like alien eggs and then it went back to
[ __ ] and then more alien eggs instinct
ah I know it didn't stick if the water
isn't there to mask the
now it didn't stink white let me ask you
guys why baby [ __ ] why do you have to
[ __ ] in a hole if it's nature you have
to bury it
why because you cuz they nobody steps in
comedian [ __ ] way worse than regular
people [ __ ] oh yeah just nachos and
[ __ ] quesadillas why Jim you wouldn't
want to dig a hole I certainly would not
just on solid ground how would you feel
though if some of your camp mates like
your your cohorts like Bob Kelly and Ari
Shaffir stepped in your [ __ ] I'm I'm
trying to think of its like how would
somebody describe a sunset or the birth
of a child or say joy right I'm trying
to think of what pure joy is maybe you
just go like this nice there barefoot my
buddies just stepped in my [ __ ]
nice nice I remember when my friend mark
Rosenberg we were too [ __ ] out in the
outside in Edison New Jersey and we were
sitting there in the [ __ ] grass and
Mark leaned back and he put his hand in
a fresh pile of dog [ __ ] dude it was so
fresh it was like he pulled it up a
shitty [ __ ] grass a grass pieces he
leaned back ready for ready for a nice
moment of sunshine and directly with the
dog that is disgust it's one of the
greatest memories I'm ever gonna have
that is 49 that was I was probably eight
when that happened so maybe or nine
that's 40 years ago and I remember it as
clearly as I can see you guys and the
joy has not abated one ounce did you get
a good laugh out of it when it happened
it was as a kid as an adult that's great
as a kid that's like [ __ ] it's it's
this you can't you can't find words as a
child to describe your buddy put his
hand in dogs is why Jim became a
comedian for the rest of his life for
the last 40 years he's been searching to
replace that laugh and it has not
happened I've been looking for that
laughs since yet night since [ __ ]
come camping take a nice [ __ ] in the
woods and [ __ ] [ __ ] in my tent I'll
never get that childhood joy back of
just watching my friend put his hand
Duty no because all the pressures of
adult heard her come on how about the
time you [ __ ] in my barrel in the hotel
room I was talking about that on Sam's
what me and Sam we're out in LA yes
we told me that with Natasha and and and
Moshe yeah I mentioned I [ __ ] in your in
your [ __ ] garbage bag excuse you have
chelsea peretti yeah a shilling in my
room like why are they Johnny hilarious
go to another floor and leave my barrel
you did yeah like I do clean this [ __ ]
mm-hmm nah [ __ ] it just took it
what got on the elevator with a box yeah
only me I'm the only [ __ ] I know you
it's perfect - is like a dark you look I
got it I had to I'd it I was like what
is and then I look it was like a ice
cream gag of [ __ ] yeah it was terrible
this black dude imagine like black tar
heroin so you guys hike up yes
you shouldn't in a you know we hiked up
hiked up to hello chip it we hiked down
no but you could call [ __ ] I like a ship
in you make me ship it yeah I had to
make my own [ __ ] but you make your own
ship it okay but if I'm a rookie could
you help me with it
why you have to figure their own [ __ ] if
the YouTube [ __ ] that's charming if
you're gonna kiss somebody you only come
on plant one right here on the ship it
was bad so okay so you hiked up yeah I
got the mountain yes sir wait and this
is in Westchester the best gesture this
is in yeah Catskills okay one up
Catskills okay so you hike up the
mountain yes make a [ __ ] pit no hike up
hike back down the other side to the
lake right you're like just go around
what go around what the mountain yeah
you can't too big this is the only wood
there's only a couple ways in and
they're all [ __ ] kind of up and down
yeah the annoying diddly well if you're
hiking it's not that's kind of walking
uphill is not fun watch right walking
downhill is worse
no it's funner you can run real quick no
it hurts your legs worse Troy you like
walking uphill or downhill downhill
definitely occur to you it's a yes they
would ever say and what you do pretty
much okay
whatever blows it's the war it's [ __ ]
blow
everything riding a bicycle uphill all
of it sucks it was pretty [ __ ] tough
exactly it was really tough so then you
walk downhill downhill was easy but it
hurt you it hurts cause you gotta yeah
he'll hurt your heart like mentally like
in and your breath is gone downhill hurt
your leg cuz you gotta stabilize
yourself that means yeah your knees yeah
your knees and your quads [ __ ] hurt
so then get to the bottom of the
mountain a set set up camp make a [ __ ]
pit
we have no you set up camp first oh okay
and then you realize what are you
bending down putting your tent pull the
sticks in and you're like oh I gotta
take a hot [ __ ] Italian sub [ __ ]
right and you have an Italian sub before
you uh before we left
yeah the height is that camping food uh
well no we brought camping food - okay
little of you guys had subs right before
was Joe listing do is you gotta stop
we're gonna be hungry on the hike were
like okay we have subs and Ari forgot
his sub in my car that's great so I
split my sub with our how do you forget
a sub I don't know does that mean your
car when you got back - it smells like
sub yeah a little like turkey and cheese
the next day
yeah then you set up the tent you set up
your camp and then I was like I gotta go
take a hot one right and I was a little
nervous do you go off cuz I don't get
nervous talking nervous nice I was a
little nervous because I'm a little
heavy and I didn't know squatting down
how long I could squat I'm a little
heavy yeah you want to correct him Jim
because I guess okay nice and watch your
legs are tired from up and down hill
terrible your feet hurt it's a band you
to go and create your shine when you
bring a toilet chair I actually went
that'd be a great um a camping thing
like a chair that yes I'm saying well
you know you bring chairs up once in a
while there should be an option you know
what Jim's not gonna say it on the air
comes to invent it he wants to bring
this to the shark tank well you could
have wrapped it just to have like a flat
thing with a hole in the middle like a
toilet seat wraps around the ideas we're
saving it for shark tank wraps around
the tree who the [ __ ] wants that yep
that's a terrible idea why there's no
surprise just like the word propriety
yeah he does I watched our tank last
night because you do you want you lean
against a tree you put you back against
lure them up and then you you dig the
hole underwear you're a baby
I'll let you this is hard way your
[ __ ] would be this is far from the
rest of the party boys ready for 150 200
yards feet away yeah sure for privacy
yeah well yeah you don't want to [ __ ] in
there you don't want to like if Joe has
to go hang the bear bag so nesco gets a
bear bag you have to hang the food at
night you can't leave it new bear bag
that's where your strawberry come
[Laughter]
giggling through the whole thing I know
it just made me you know I charmed by
sorry yeah Jim sometimes looks in the
mirror and goes yeah yeah so dad Sam go
back to you
you put the bear bag up in a tree branch
yeah Canterbury just reach up and grab
the bear bag not if he's not if you put
it up right not if you put it in the
right spot like I think it's ten feet up
and you gotta climb a tree to get it no
you just throw throw a carabiner with
some cordage over a tree branch around
four feet out around and then hang it
down put the bag on it I see
pull it up because the Bears not gonna
pull the goddamn thing they don't have
some no they don't they're not dexterous
no yeah so you and then you tired put a
twig on it or branch and let it go and
it goes back up and stops halfway down
so even if they climb the tree out on
the branch they can't get it because
it's around four feet down from the
branch separate tents are saying
separate tents unfortunately that wasn't
your fault you know I wanted to get a
nice big one tent one blanket maybe a
nice mini Black Mountain [ __ ]
Sandspit little tepee that's right so I
can put it in Joe list but a little
nervous Joe right forward on that I
think I think we got we all got tents
one person tents
but I think next time I go I want to get
this amick am okay
hammock it's because being on the ground
right and then around 1:15 in the
morning a pack of wild coyotes came
through the camp oh my god it it was the
probably one of the scariest things I
would be goddamn terrified dude I would
laugh you would I laugh at coyotes Wow
coyotes sound like a wolf for like a
second and then they turn into something
else what is the other thing sounds like
a wolf being attacked by out something
bigger oh my god they just they they do
that [ __ ] yeah
but they were only like AAB maybe 50
yards away from us did you guys scream
shut the [ __ ] up dude let me - Joel is
is an anxious guy anyways he was
actually nervous about a scratch he got
about get it getting infected so he had
to open up the first-aid kit to put
Neosporin on his gut because he was like
do you think I'm gonna get in fact at 45
minutes is this alright this is the
curse mark for him like not even
bleeding and then a pack of wild coyotes
keep the pressure smelled his a cut hey
maybe it was a little rice pilaf I made
a rice pilaf I did him in this hot rice
pilaf what are the stakes did you wish
didn't she wish you had a gun at that
moment though when there's all those
animal like just in case I had it I had
a very big knife and I had bear spray
that I bought barely helped that would
help well coyotes but then sprays far -
it's like it's almost like bug spray
bear spray where you like it you could
hit me from where you all it with a jet
of bear spray that's [ __ ] brutal yeah
I was scared because I knew about bears
I studied the black bears I knew would
be fine if we hang there and they're not
gonna really [ __ ] with you listen with
Cubs or whatever right if you stumble
across them they have timber
rattlesnakes up there a lot of them
what's there's rattlesnakes in New York
timber rattlesnakes yeah up up well we
were hiking yeah there's hundreds like
where there's rattlesnakes
I don't know we wanted to go hiking you
have to be when you know don't step on
them terribly they have a rattle I mean
let you know I don't know why you would
hike where there's rattlesnakes and
bears and coyotes well I didn't know
about the coyotes I didn't hear [ __ ] cuz
I did a lot of research on this hike
right and I didn't hear nobody mentioned
[ __ ] coyotes how bummed out would you
guys be if you're sitting there
site right and getting ready to turn in
for the night yeah and some little bear
cubs just walk on to walk into your area
I would [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants yeah I
would run for my tent get that bear
spray and watch REO Joe being eaten that
would slowly back away you would I know
you got to make those decisions before
you go like what if this happened yeah
even like remember when you went to Iraq
didn't you make decisions you had like
alright if this happens I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm just gonna die no I I don't
remember to be honest but I just I know
I wasn't prepared I had no contingency
me and Colin were like are we break a CD
in half we'll [ __ ] stab somebody the
neck you know we'll go [ __ ] it you know
try to hide in the sand plans we would
try to make a plans like if something
happens if we get captured
just let it [ __ ] them we'll just annoy
him until either laugh I'll cut our
heads off so what was the plaintiff a
black bear came with their cubs if a
black bear came with her cubs I'll go
ahead and I picked up Ichabod you don't
say get out of here or I'm gonna throw
it you might know what it's Marcus you
might know no because the mama bear is
not gonna want to want Jim to her cubs
Oh she'll go okay all right back up
she's gonna slowly back up right okay
grab her at the car take the other cub
and just say no no the other couple be
mad be like [ __ ] that mom and like no no
no no let this little thing could take
your brother we'll get your brother back
that's right now that's right smart that
did not happen thank God
how amazing was that deer footage by the
way did we talk about that on the air
didn't we
why I don't think what do your footage
the footage of the [ __ ] the hippo
chasing the baby deer mostly we talked
about it on the air do you see it I
don't think so that's why I don't think
so I mean I just remind you of a mother
and her [ __ ] dog man nature it works
yeah
the footage looks for a hippo chasing
baby deer yeah I was [ __ ] creepy
though coyotes were [ __ ] terrible
is it angry hippo crushes antelope no
baby deer say bye guys wait that's him
thing is is that like there's no ice on
it like you can't see oh is it a
cantaloupe or head you level no is a
nice fresh cantaloupe I love a
cantaloupe yeah nice fresh cantaloupe
hippos are the most dangerous animal
there is they say everybody yeah yeah
they are the [ __ ] the one with a
mother gets in front of the [ __ ] uh I
uh so what was your plan if the bear
attack happened well the bear attack
thing if it happened I had the bear
spray a knife you would let your friends
do it well I will you have to kind of
make that decision correct you know I
got a kid right you know what I mean
but the coyote thing when it happened it
was dead they just went to sleep and it
was so relaxing it was so we had a fire
going we're smoking Cubans it was crazy
cool and then you hear the zipper I was
already in bed you hear the zippers go
up and people rustling in the tent and
we're like it's yeah did you see these
frogs going off it's you're in your for
our walk from anywhere oh my god so
there's no way if something happens
someone has to walk out four hours and
four hours back right maybe six hours if
you ran you know probably do it probably
after walk out four hours but maybe
they'll bring a car back or you can't
get a car over there you get a car up
one of the roads may be afraid or
something you're looking at you're
looking at a long time so then we always
sleep around 1:15 we're just lying there
and they're just so quiet and so awesome
and then these coyotes dude pull up can
you pull up a coyote sound pack a cut
it's the worst sound I've ever heard in
my life I'd like to hear what it sounds
like I it was so and they went off for
like a minute and a half and then there
was dead silence between the three of us
and everybody was still up oh okay okay
here's here's coyote sounds that just
sounds like a dog barking no that's not
that scary ah no that's that's their
knees
and that's how you know there's a pack
of them - yeah that's terrifying
now I'll go out and pattern their pride
nice well you're good with Hannibal yeah
it's not dogs
yeah fifty fifty yards in one piece of
cheese get a squeaky toy boy give this
cheese there's no there's nobody around
there's nobody around and then you just
hear Joe listen ah Bob what do we do
about that I don't know and he went what
he was like an angry with me it's like
what is this mad at me yeah cuz I I did
all the real guy knew what to do about
bears and right teaching him all this
[ __ ] about the bear and blubber and he's
like what you tired the hairspray took a
[ __ ] I had the best I literally over my
tent as soon as I heard that I grabbed
my big knife which I've been happy if he
took the bear spray with him when he
took a [ __ ] and then while he was
[ __ ] he accidentally dropped the
bear spray and then it was covered in
[ __ ] know what I would be happier if he
dropped it and it fired into his [ __ ]
the bear spray but I gave I gave I had I
had a really big knife right
I had my bushcraft knife oh I forgot you
had one custom-made I had I had yeah -
good
could I have my bushcraft knife I gave
Ari a knife a pretty nice knife from
Finland okay and then I gave Joe this
fucked-up little buck knife and it was
kind of dull right and I know it he
didn't and it had a trick to open it you
had to push this thing and he he
couldn't he had to have me open his
knife so the whole time Jose Jose thing
was more like Joe why you just let us
take care of ya yeah I was like you can
you know cut your meat with that right
then right I didn't want him to get hurt
you can whittle with you oh dude it was
terrifying we were sitting there for a
half hour waiting for just hear somebody
being [ __ ] chewed on now did you hear
them for the entire half hour did you
hear them once they want to win they
came in they called each other
it was [ __ ] terrifying yeah because
in my mind if they're calling each other
and assembling yeah I'd be like one of
those coyotes is telling the other
coyotes there's a bunch of [ __ ] nude
nicks that decided to walk across a
mountain and sleep outside let's eat
them yeah and I didn't know anything
about coyotes no I know so no it didn't
show was pissed he went like this yeah
what yeah who he was [ __ ] very a is
he outdoorsy Joe is a good hiker we've
never done this and this isn't a
campsite it's a guy they called
primitive campsites so you kind of go up
the trail and then these little areas
you can spend the night or a couple
nights up in the mountains them and the
Catskills them everywhere but um you
know there's no running water like we
had to fill up our water bags in the
river and we're gonna filter it no
there's these patio filler it's a Sawyer
filter you attach it to your bladder
your hole your your bag or you put it on
a bottle and drink right out of the
bottle are you worried that you have a
tapeworm yeah yes you can't you can't we
don't have we don't have that [ __ ] here
really oh it's it's it just filters out
all the [ __ ] you can drink that the
water you're drinking is from the same
[ __ ] they just filter it for their
professional plants that filter it not
something you tie to your [ __ ] water
bottle like a fern I'm pretty sure that
Poland Spring the lilacs are working
that's good so you have to just sit
there and wait like how do you know that
they're really gone gone do you we never
slept none as soon as the Sun came up
your zippers yeah well it wasn't we're
gonna do it again in a couple weeks
why because we just get it cuz I just
but I like I said we had the tents which
I feel like I'm gonna switch over to a
hammock because I I feel like you can
get out of a hammock quicker and you're
up off the ground so there's no snakes
there's no that's smart the snake thing
is smart but how high up off the ground
with the hammock be it'd be like I don't
know a couple three feet three feet
maybe two feet so I'm like that but
you're on an animal still come and just
bite you in your sleep you can come and
bite but I could get the [ __ ] out I
could roll out of it and [ __ ]
somebody no no no this ammok one and I'm
get I want to get yeah it's it's you can
actually it has a sleeping pad in it
thank you I'm a side sleeper so you can
lie down you're so you can lie on your
side
but it also has a built-in bug net so
you just get in it and zip the [ __ ]
around and it has a tarp that goes over
it so if arranged you don't get wet
that's fun it's pretty cool right and
it's sleeping in a hammock is one of the
most comfortable ways you can sleep
because you slap beds
I mean camping wise I was gonna say
camping at the end of that but like in a
tent I was sleeping on the floor and I
got I got this [ __ ] big blowup pad
would you sleep on and in the middle of
the night the thing popped so I was just
sleeping on the ground and that sucked
cuz it was called I would hate after the
coyote thing my sleeping pad popped
right and I was like [ __ ] so I had to
keep blowing it up cuz it had a little
leak try to keep blowing up and I'm
rustling in my tent and I scared the
[ __ ] out of both of them because they
thought I was being attacked I was just
pissed off [ __ ] my knees and hip bone
were called yeah III would be I would
have such severe anxiety especially at
sleep time comment on this trip there is
no way come on well guess I hate that it
would I would hate that the apex camping
shelter and hammock it looks kind of a
no ammok oh okay yeah amok amok this one
though it looks uncomfortable to
collapse no no go to the bucket mmm okay
is you it's like a bed in the air am
okay is the I would I mean I was a [ __ ]
it's from Norway to the company and
they're [ __ ] it's it's unbelievable
you look uncomfortable you can actually
snug this one you can actually sit up in
like a chip you pull the straps and it
sits you up like a chair and then you
let them go and you lie back but you can
actually it just feels that it looks
like it has a sleeping pad in it so
you're sleeping on an air mass mattress
in the air it looks like you're waiting
to be attacked it literally looks like a
guy it's like a [ __ ] little
single-person spacecraft yeah yeah but
there but as far as comfortable wise
sleep it on the ground you have to make
sure you clear the ground make sure it's
level you put a thing underneath if it
rains blah blah blah something like this
like any other things I've researched is
that the things that suck about hammocks
is that you're kind of cocooned in like
this
sure but this one you
waiting there for a bear to attack you
right you can't do anything you're
literally a lesson treat hanging two
feet in the air I'd rather be a treat
that I can get the [ __ ] out of it for
the bear because of that you're right
because of that bug net thing is you're
literally already stuck in a net yeah
that bear comes and attacks you you are
like you're not like a [ __ ] a cod
stuck in a that's right
yeah oh you gotta tie them around a tree
who them so easy you wrap it wrap it
around the tree dude it looks terrible
it's great I would be tearing I would be
tied to piss that's the thing you can
just zip you you on this one
you just roll out of it on a tent you
have to like a one-person tent you have
to unzip it there's no way I'm trying to
get your shoes you have to get your
stuff on you got to kind of crawl out
you know it depends on the 10 second
stepfather thank you tents are hard
enough to get in and out of this is
impossible I'll bet I have a big blowup
10 a 4 person
I mean hey Moscone backyard hammocks are
hard enough to get in and out what are
you talking about this one's impossible
no everybody gets all wrapped up in them
no yeah just this one you just sit in do
it if I went with you I'd be terrified
and I'd be trying to come up with
reasons to keep you guys up all night so
I didn't have to sleep by myself why you
come with me I'll get a two-person tent
I don't want to sleep in with me no
because then it's an even weirder no
it's not gonna get weird it's gonna get
warmer not weird
wrong W I'm sure warmer but I feel like
this come on
hey Nora Murray's will start to come up
with you and he'll get it'll good come
on you wear that little you wear that
little number you used to wear I don't
want to do that anymore okay why not you
come with me I get a two-person tent me
and you will get in there I get a nice
little pad get a nice little W in an
intern and you remember the stuff you
would do what kind of stuff first run
things gonna happen I'm gonna reach
around put my little my middle finger in
your belly button just to make sure you
warm oh my god that's a cool way to hold
them they're from the back Jill yeah and
tries to scamper away you dig into the
belly but that's the way if I got
another scooter I'd have Sam ride from
the back with both fingers in my belly
but get the other one in there there's
there's a lot of room you just here at
golf one finger my bellybutton in just
me you just hear my hernia pop back in
at no point at no point of my life
am I ever going to be outdoor camping is
not gonna happen look it I don't even
get a clamp to tell you I used to be
into it I used to be into it and I got
out of it
living in the city but now I'm getting
back into it but you would you would
like it no I will you like fishing
whatever house that boat you got I got
I'm going up and using every year okay I
use it every year at my own it's at my
uncle Jimmy's he lives on on Golden Pond
that actual Lake here's a huge house up
there and I have my boat up there and we
go pond fishing all the time I like
staying in my basement
I like playing pop G I like watching my
shows my program you know there's
nothing take max hiking all the time we
go out [ __ ] woods hiked around Don's
going with me we're going camping I'm
taking the kid and the wife to an actual
campsite you know family campsite it's
called car camping you pull up you set
up a tent what do you do if you take a
kid camping it's just you and your son
are you and your daughter yeah and then
the adult has a heart attack and dies
the kid [ __ ] lives in the woods
becomes Tarzan makes friends with
Cassini it happened to him in the hot in
the hotel he was out with his kid yeah
you be gamma smoke Lee let me kid was
like 12 yeah you only have to make sure
you before you go hiking I mean last
year I mean not like six months ago
every test in the world done on my heart
all you do okay yeah soon as Colin had a
heart attack I [ __ ] got everything
done did you get it all checked out at
all no how are you good
I have over the years she I mean even
though you're in shape you should get
plaque and [ __ ] like that
yeah you know she you know you you might
you might have a nice hot Widowmaker
nothing to be a widow be a [ __ ]
bachelor maker yeah there's nothing well
the about this that would appeal to me
and I'd be sitting there and I'd go I'm
camping in the woods right now if I knew
that I had a night off like where I'm
not working and not with the wife and
kid I just got in the movie theater
that's where I would want to be in a
movie
I like going to the movies I'm telling
you there's something about being out in
the [ __ ] woods that no phones no
service
I don't know conversation I like that we
had a set up camp we had a light of fire
we had to keep it going wrote just come
over come over my house we'll go hang
out on the deck will leave the phones in
the living room same [ __ ] same [ __ ] all
the same thing a [ __ ] a toilet exactly
you can go inside and use the toys I
mean look the one I mean [ __ ]
outside was no pun intended
shitty actually complete pun intended
total but it was and then when it's time
to go to bed we're all sitting out on
the on the deck we can smoke a little
Cuban cigars we can put a little bonfire
going or something and then when
everybody goes like all right you guys
ready to pack it in it's like yeah go
back to your houses and sleep in your
beds like no no no it was fun our our he
does it all the time he's actually hikes
and does it Joe hikes a lot too but we
they hike a lot yeah cuz you there's a
nap you have I have a my phone that you
can just wherever you are type in it
shows you the trails around me and re
last year for just for laughs me are in
big J I remember we rented a cabin in
the woods and we went hiking out there
from the better we were supposed to go
camping but it was raining it was all
[ __ ] up so but we planned this two
year ago and it was cool we're gonna do
it again you wanna do it there's a
waterfall one we're gonna go up in the
Catskills are you gonna try to do it
like Bushkill party boys bushcraft party
boys it that is what it always will be
and we're gonna add somebody else to the
but another fourth are you going to camp
in a cabin again or you go to my Twitter
all of a bush-league party boys no I
think this year I think the next time we
go camping
I'm actually gonna switch over to one of
these hit this this hammock thing cuz
the tent thing on the ground I you know
like you have to I don't know did
worried about like a [ __ ] snake
coming a [ __ ] panic what happens if
you find a couple of redwoods parking a
parking lot and used to all right nice
half way throws I don't got it
do you ever go you're in the woods and
you're lost and you're like don't worry
I know the way home and then you walk
for four hours and then you realize you
walked in a circle that's not
Tarantino's one of his editors died like
that woman is that right I Susanna
whatever and she was like yeah one of
his uh because his editors were amazing
I see it in my movie I think she was
that always happens in my movies there
was I just saw the Sally manky yeah a
lot of people die like that
like they'll just hike and then get lost
yeah
try hiking with her dog in the severe
heat and she was fifty I guess she just
couldn't whatever okay guess what AC in
the house it's perfect yeah I don't I
don't do that type of [ __ ] I'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ] hiking the Appalachian
Trail I'm not doing it I'm I have a map
it on my phone it actually records where
I am my wife can check it you ever hiked
the Oregon Trail no no I did not
I use a wagon that [ __ ] every time caulk
the wagon [ __ ] it let's roll the dice
baby nice nice I I don't do that crazy
[ __ ] I like hiking up a little bit
couple miles maybe three miles for hours
you like maybe four we did four miles
this one or something like that it's
four hours the most she ever did away
from this realization this was the this
staying over I've done big hikes up in
New Hampshire but this list I've always
come back yeah I've never hiked out and
stayed that was you you can't think
about it and that all of a sudden that
when the Coyotes as soon as the Coyotes
I was like a weird
we're weird we have no help right like I
can't just cut my phone doesn't work
dude we got a raccoon that keeps
knocking over our garbage can you'll get
the same wildlife in my backyard I
promise you that it'll be the same
experience well raccoons make a weird
noise too right
there was one screaming in the middle of
night and I was like what is that
they're screaming yeah and we'll let me
know those raccoons those original title
sounds of the record doesn't work they
were slaughtering the spring raccoon
safety clicks migrans
why would anybody care of all the
raccoons were here it's fine
dude you take the tails off to make a
raccoon dr. Lecter what became of your
raccoon he bit me he bit me an
aggression and
to put him down menace nobody worse the
worst I hate Rankin they just shot one
across the street the cops came and put
a nice hot 22 in his [ __ ] head good
day yeah I think it was a [ __ ] rabbit
well he's out in the daylight do it and
you gotta shoot him if they're out in
the daylight I say that certain people
do the rabbit
yeah if raccoons are running around in
the daylight or they're getting close to
people they're rabid yeah there's a shot
a coyote in my name is - coyote cow they
are coyotes ha-joon you put your Chi on
yeah yeah they shot uh they shot one of
those Monday but - not a guarantee
indicator of rabies you see raccoons are
primarily nocturnal they often do get
some stuff done during the day
raccoons like I'm trying to go about my
business
he was walking from point A to point B
he must be batshit crazy I have a lot to
do today and I happen to not be
nocturnal at the moment well I found out
that coyotes won't [ __ ] they still
they'll take a child right or dogs or
cats right they're not gonna [ __ ] with
us ladies small dogs yeah oh this video
this [ __ ] up video disc of this guy's
jaw goes to the bad guy in this guy owed
hopped the fence grabbed the dog jumped
over the fence stood on the top with the
dog just in its mouth looked at the guy
and then just by dog guard
oh that's so [ __ ] out yeah yeah I
think Nicole Biggins from the morning
mash up her first dog died via coyote or
some kind of bird or something like that
yeah they let the coyote go I mean they
let the dog go like run around in the
woods or whatever yeah and that was the
end of that little poodle oh yeah a
little toy whatever it was a homer a
knee and all that well what a nice snack
that is oh yeah I got a big Labradoodle
so I don't think my dog seen you [ __ ]
yeah bigger dogs they have a hard time
like I found out after I did research
and he was like we were pretty alright
they don't know it they were not gonna
[ __ ] with us yeah yeah but there's a lot
of them I'd be terrified it was probably
around 4 I'd be terrified yeah I was I
was [ __ ] my pants right and you know
I was more scared because you know you
had a [ __ ] pit right next to so you did
not need to do that but that's how
scared you were I like this [ __ ] pit
yeah yeah I'm looking at these are
videos what choice to play them where
coyotes are attacking family pets and
one woman saved her dolly she ran out
yes there he was tearing the dog up yeah
look
[ __ ] thing there's big dumb ears yeah
[ __ ] kya how there's a coyote way
though that's actually a small one how
much those little rascals weigh how much
is a highway 60 or 70 yeah yeah some of
them some of them are bigger than oxen
they're not you know they're not get one
coyote is not gonna take a st. Bernard
done no no but a bunch of them good 515
245 yeah yes my dog weighs like sixty do
you see that video last week of the two
links is yelling at each other oh let me
see the Lynx is yelling at each other I
want to see the Lynx is yeah I'd love to
see that yeah it's like a family feud
episode but with lynxes what are they
what are they router which one of us has
a name like blonde the Mod Squad links
these links every relationship another
villain this is Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts meeting two gunshots a nice
[ __ ] coat made nice feet dick oh my
God look how long their feet are they
vote they judge the girl filming it
freaked out a little bit she's there in
a car though yeah so they touched heads
for a moment and then swatted they keep
bowing their heads next to each other
and then they don't touch but the minute
that they touch they freak out will they
let you pet them right now it's like
every fight in the West Village on a
Saturday night they're starting to shell
out a thing like what are we fighting
about really yeah come on guys just a
piece of [ __ ] its amazed that sprit e
cool that's it I don't know it like I
understand videotaping and if you're
from a car but these people that
videotape the one guy that got killed
try to get a selfie with a black bear
yeah ah I love that he got [ __ ]
mauled I love when people are like take
these dumb risks and then they don't pay
off there is no upside to this if I seen
a black bear I am slowly backing the
[ __ ] away from it we
driving to the those outlets we were
talking about what very Commons ones
love would very common all right stinks
and you don't like I hate we're very
[ __ ] comments what do you go by
yourself
it's one of the shittiest places about
this bear is ripping this guy up yeah
that's oh my god yes black bear dummy
but we were driving he died we were
driving on the way right and you could
see like there's like it's it's a
mountainous terrain as you're driving
towards Woodbury Commons and we looked
at the window and there was a little
baby bear just in plain eyesight of
everybody by itself walking on like the
walking and bike path it's right there
in the woods and all I could think about
was just how [ __ ] you would be if you
came across that thing as you walk yeah
no not like no I meant like that no but
the mothers probably not far behind
unless the Bears go into that very
Commons could be looking for maybe
there's a sale might be yeah looking for
low bear pants this [ __ ] idiot was
trying to get his camera back to good
what a dummy good which guy the guy with
the stupid he's trying to pull his
camera away from the bear he's no longer
with us like that maybe no maybe that
bear had his sleeve or something maybe
was round he he had it it's funny how
nobody well like there's a lot of people
there then a dog that stupid cat our dog
regardez is helping you nobody is
helping him and the bear doesn't give a
[ __ ] that all these people are watching
someone's just filming it of course a
bear doesn't care is what bears do yeah
[ __ ] that no way [ __ ] that they don't
tell them to it like that bear man
documentary I'm the guy who did the bear
man documentary I ended up getting eaten
by a bear was he that's what he wanted
the dog just hanging out
don't you know there's a big [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] pit a bear [ __ ] pit right exactly
that's your life that your life's work
you're now in a bear [ __ ] pit what about
the guy who got attacked by a grizzly
twice and then made it out walked for
miles with just his head sliced open his
arm broken mm-hmm and made it to the
hospital he survived survived giant
gashes in his head right and he's
literally go do it he's like video
taping ago and I just got [ __ ] up by a
grizzly twice he's the man then if he
survived
yeah say people who serve all yes this
guy yeah life sucks in bear country
he's had a that's his head hanging off
come at me from about 80 yards put his
hat back on and I sprayed the [ __ ] out
of it with bear spray and then I on my
face and protected the back of my neck
she got my head good I don't know what's
under my hat
oh my ear my arm oh gosh oh my goodness
yeah I got don't get a fight with a bear
dude and in my shoulder this is you Bob
now this brown bears that's a brown bear
have fun camping Bob that's a yeah this
is your life now
dude I have bear bells do you know what
makes you tow
yeah I have a bear bail on my bag
ding-a-ling-a-ling Lee do you think the
top of the food chain the beer hit the
best care yes city's exactly in cars we
learned how to be guns shelter and
transportation and tools I have a
shelter I'm gonna get a nice [ __ ]
hammock then lay like a [ __ ] bridge
oh right in the tree
I said Italian fat meat hanging off
right there you understand good stuff
that bear bear bear legends are made of
yeah honey this [ __ ] goggle boy oh my
god and how much did he weigh 420 I
walked up to the prosciutto hanging out
of the tree yeah actually you'd actually
see bears pulling their cellphones out
filming you like I can't believe our
good luck yeah they've been tweeting we
just Italian deli guys come here this
Joe Liston Ari Shaffir would have so
much time to get away oh my god they can
actually fold the tents up
[Laughter]